we had a tweet recently suggesting we do
a video on aloha net which i think we've
had brief discussions about before but it's
some really early form of kind of um network
is it was it something to do with hawaii i
mean you know you're the hawaiian shirt guy
yeah so um yeah no aloha is probably the sort of
grandfather of pretty much all networks that we
use today i think it was 68 the norman abramson
started to work on this technology along with
others and the technology that was used has
influenced ethernet it's influenced gprs
satellite communication is still in use today
in various forms so it was based in hawaii he
was at the university of hawaii and they had a
big expensive ibm mainframe that they wanted to
provide access to but because hawaii is a
series of islands they couldn't just run
cables everywhere and so they decided that
they would build a wireless network in 1968
this wasn't off-the-shelf equipment right yeah
they had to develop this all themselves you
couldn't just go and buy a cisco wi-fi access
point and stick it up on top of a tower because
cisco hadn't been created yet that was still 12
years in the future if not more 15 years in the
future and of course cisco only existed because of
the technology that was developed as part of aloha
so they were literally developing all this from
themselves and so what they had is that they
had two radio frequencies that they'd use they
used one to transmit from the ibm computer out
across all the islands of hawaii and then they had
another radio frequency that they used to transmit
back from all the terminals that people were using
back to the central computer now they had a sort
of a simple situation because they had a very
definite model that they had one computer the
ibm mainframe it was at this point they had data
going from the ibm mainframe to all of the other
machines and they were receiving data from many
machines transmission was a one-to-many problem
and that's great because you then only have one
computer that's sending anything so that computer
can break its data down into packets which is what
they did and then sequence them so they get sent
out and there's no sort of corruption as that
data is transmitted actually what they did was
that they had another computer that sat in front
of the ibm mainframe they had a hp computer they
bought an hp mini computer and they dedicated
that to doing all this processing and splitting
data into packets reassembling it passing the data
back on to the ibm mainframe they refer to this
hp computer as the menu hewn and i apologize if
i've mispronounced that name which is a hawaiian
word for elf they sort of played on the word elf
because it was based on some of the ideas that
were being developed as part of the arpanet for
the interface message processor so they were sort
of imp elf you can see how the sort of train of
thought moves along so they have this secondary
computer the menu that was sitting between the
ibm and everything else so it got data from the
ibm and could then transmit it out as packets to
all the terminals wherever they are over the radio
frequency in a serial fashion modulating it deep
as it needed to be and they just transmitted it
out so sending data from the ibm to the terminals
was fine the terminals could then receive the
packets see if it was for them if it wasn't
displayed on screen if it wasn't you just ignore
it and so on they didn't worry about security in
those days i'm sure it was just clear text and
receive it but they had much more of a problem
getting data back so when you type something into
the computer you need to send that data back to
the ibm mainframe so that you can deal with things
and so what they realize what the sort of key
contribution that norman abrams and and the
others who are working on this sort of realized
was how can we send that data back to the ibm
computer via the menu in as simple a way as
possible and the problem you've got is that
you've got several computers
dotted all around the islands
and it's potentially possible that two of them
might transmit at the same time and if two of them
were to transmit at the same time it's the same
as two people speaking at the same time they would
interfere with each other and the computer at the
other end wouldn't be able to receive the signal
and so they would corrupt each other's messages
so they were trying to make sure that any computer
could transmit at any point but that you didn't
have corruption of the messages as they were sent
what they realized was that they didn't need the
data to be received correctly necessarily the
first time they received it that it would actually
be okay if it could be eventually received that
you might transmit it and it wouldn't get
received so then you'd have to transmit it again
and so what they realize if you relax things and
say okay we want eventual packet delivery as it's
called we want to be able to receive it at some
point you can actually start to say well okay we
can transmit at any point to make best use of the
bandwidth i mean you could use say time division
multiplexing where you break your channel your
radio channel up into segments that are some
percentage of a second long and you say okay this
computer can only transmit in that point of time
and then this computer can only transmit at this
point of time but if you do that you find that
you're not actually using the bandwidth that well
because most of the time particularly on something
like a terminal people are typing and they'll
type something then they'll read the response
and then they'll type something else actually that
doesn't use the bandwidth you've got available
that effectively what they realized was they could
make best use of the bandwidth by just saying okay
you can send the packet whenever you like so any
of the terminals if they had some data to be sent
you type something into the keyboard it would then
just attempt to send that data to the ibm via the
menu so it's modulated into the radio signal send
it out over the radio transmitter it'd be received
by the menu and then it'd be sort of decoded
and passed to the ibm computer to do whatever it
was you wanted it to do and if you were the only
thing transmitting that would be absolutely great
you could send the data out and it would be
received but what happens if there's two of you
transmitting at the same time so you're typing on
your computer i'm typing on mine and we send the
data at the same time well of course the data is
received by the menu is a mix of the two messages
so it won't make any sense it'll be corrupted but
they realize that this was okay because what they
got the computer to do is that when you receive
the data correctly it sent out another bit of
data back to the machine that sent it saying
i've received what you sent correctly so you
would send your data from your terminal it would
get sent up and the menu you would receive and
you would send a message back saying yep got that
acknowledge and then you'd know it'd been received
and what they realized was if you just
send it out and you don't get that response
that means the menu didn't receive it and if the
many who didn't receive it you just send it again
and then hopefully that time he gets through
and then you get the acknowledge response and
if you don't you send it again until you get
the acknowledged response and your terminal
does exactly the same thing it gets the doesn't
get an acknowledged response so waits a certain
amount of time and the key thing is you need
some sort of algorithm in place to sort of decide
who sends after what sort of time if everyone
just waited the same amount of time you'd get
the same sort of problem and things and so
it just waited for a short amount of time
pick it randomly use it based on the station id
various approaches they could use i can't remember
exactly which one they used in the low car it
doesn't matter and then you resend your data and
eventually it will get through and what they found
was that this actually provided really good use of
the bandwidth most people could transmit when they
wanted to but could also detect packet collisions
when two people tried to transmit at the same time
and recover from them by resending the packets now
it meant that the terminals had to have a little
bit of intelligence to them to be able to sort of
keep track of the packets and check whether it'd
been received or not but you could implement that
relatively straightforwardly and so it produced
a system that could work and this was operational
by about 1971 and used all over hawaii and then
as they were developing it they did some sort
of later improvements one thing they realized is
that if you just allow people to send at any point
then you could have a packet collision
which could destroy two packets
if only a single bit collided in between them
both packets would be destroyed um you wouldn't
receive them correctly that's a better way of
putting that and so you'd have to resend them
so what they actually did in a slightly later
variation of it which is known as slotted aloha
is that they said okay you can transmit at any
time but you must align it to certain time points
and so you have all the machines synchronized and
so you can either transmit say that 0 seconds or
0.001 second or 0.002 second for example and if
you do that you then either get a packet collision
where the whole packets collide because they're
transmitted at the same time or you don't get
a packet collision because if someone starts
transmitting something and someone else wants
to transmit say about halfway through it it has
to wait until the next transmission point to
which to do it at which point they won't collide
whereas if you can say transmit at any point then
you can sort of start transmitting and then i
start transmitting and it destroys them and that
could just sink that could just be as simple as
a single bits get corrupted at the end at which
point you've destroyed the whole transmission of
two packets when if you'd waited one bit neither
packet would have been destroyed so that was
the sort of improvement that they developed
now i said that aloha net was sort of the
grandfather the granddaddy of all the sort
of different networks and that's because when
people were developing things like ethernet and
xerox park in the sort of mid-70s they'd heard of
the work it been published and they'd heard of the
word that norman abrams and his team had done
in hawaii and they sort of took the same ideas
so ethernet for example run originally ran on
a single piece of wire that stretched around
the office and the machines were literally
physically clamped onto the ethernet cable
so they but they still use the same ideas they
still said okay anyone can transmit at any point
um if the data doesn't get received then we'll
retransmit things but because they were on a
physical piece of wire they could do some extra
things to sort of for example they could see
whether someone was already transmitting and so
they could sort of say okay someone's already
transmitting i'll wait until they've finished
so they could sort of get better performance
but they were sort of very much aware of
the work that norman and his team have done
and we're building on top of that and that's
followed through into things like gprs
satellite communications they're all still using
this sort of idea you still get straight aloha
networks out there i think laura wan the sort of
iot things at times can work in that sort of a
fashion that you just literally send things
out wait for acknowledgement if you don't get
that acknowledgement then you send it out again
after a certain amount of time until the data is
eventually received so yeah really great piece
of work it provided wireless networking for the
hawaii community of the hawaii academic community
of computer scientists let's limit this to the
people who are actually using it probably way back
in the 60s 70s and yeah has really influenced the
way that sort of networking technology has been
developed diagram i'm drawing very badly here and
so on so you'd have two sets of pulses one delayed
from the other it's what we call quadrature
encoding we can actually derive from that which
direction the signal is moving in so yeah they're
very different to the originals and the important
thing is that we don't know what went into here
[MANUAL PUBLISH]